hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well a central concept
for Albert Camus particularly in his
early works like the myth of synthesis
and in its what you might call its
companion piece the the stranger is this
notion of the absurd and sometimes
people say at Albert Camus is not
strictly speaking an existentialist he
was an absurdist not not actually
correct to say that because he is in a
broad sense but the absurd is really
central to cow Moos conception of a
reality of human being and in his own
form of existentialist philosophy so
what we want to do in this video is look
at what he actually means by the absurd
and we don't want to get bogged down in
a lot of individual examples what we
want to do is look at the broadest most
overarching systemic structural
understanding of absurdity and I realize
that there's a little bit of irony there
or absurdity or however you want to put
it and this notion that we can have a
general idea of absurdity but it's their
income whose work so if you want to
really understand what he means by say
the absurd person or the absurd world or
absurdity in general you really want to
get this concept
down and you notice I've got this sort
of triatic structure here we're going to
explore that in just a few minutes we're
asking ourselves what exactly is we
observed before we explore that before
we look at some of the passages that I
think are particularly important in a
sort of systematic connected portion of
the mythos ipsus I want to bring up two
other passages that occur a little bit
later in the myth of synthesis because
they illustrate two important sides of
absurdity and of qaboos philosophy of
gentlemen so he calls the absurd lucid
reason noting its limits what does that
mean that means that when rationality
which is remember that what is
distinctive to a human being when when
reason actually explores the the world
that it knows it turns inward at itself
looks at it its own capacities it
becomes aware of the irrational not as
something that can be washed away or
done away with as a problem but it's
something that is going to play against
something that is is in a certain sense
unfixable the other passage he says that
the absurd once we become aware of it it
is a passion the most harrowing of all
now I like these two passages because
what you've got here is a really almost
exclusive exclusive emphasis on the
intellectual or the rational the
cognitive aspects of human being here
and then on the other hand we're talking
about a passion so what are we meeting
there the emotional the desirous the
effective the appetite of side of human
existence and these are both the absurd
the feeling of the absurd and the
experience of the absurd are both
integral to it they're not they're not
neatly separable from each other and as
a matter of fact that's the way it is
for human being the effective side of
human being
is not something that you can neatly
strip away from the intellectual side
even you might say concepts themselves
have their effective side to them
concepts or things that we want to think
about we want to think about we desire
they come with certain moods this is a
fairly typical stuff that you find in
existentialist philosophy this is a
theme that you see over and over and
over again whether you're looking at
Camus whether you're looking at sard
whether you're looking at Heidegger when
you're looking at Kierkegaard Nietzsche
the notion that effectivity and
rationality or the the work of the
intellect the mind and the heart are
actually interfused with each other so
that's a let's come back to this over
here why do I have this three-part this
triatic relationship
well because Camus himself says that
that's something that we have to get in
order to grasp what the absurdity
actually is there is a tendency to want
to locate the absurd in persons the
subject or to want to locate it in the
world in objects in the self in the
other trying to you know put it over
here over there those don't actually
work according to come loop so the
question that we want to think about is
well why not and the answer is contained
in in a discussion that he engages in
where he actually sort of reverses
course at a certain point he says I said
that the world is absurd so that's
locating it on this side right and you
know when you read cow Moos the stranger
you read parts of the mythos if assists
you might say ah we're stuck in this
absurd world that just doesn't make
sense
chemist says no the world itself is not
absurd he says I was too hasty and
saying that this world in itself is not
reasonable it's not rational
through-and-through
it resists what we want it to be to
become and to conform to so he says what
is absurd is the confrontation of this
irrational the world and this wild
longing for clarity whose call echoes in
the human heart we're going to get to
that in a moment but that's the person
that's the self that's the subject the
human being the absurd is a
confrontation between self and world why
is it a confrontation because the self
desires like he says the self desires
something out of the world and the world
disappoints he's not talking here merely
about not getting what you wanted out of
life in the sense that well I want to
marry somebody who has these particular
qualities or I want this kind of job or
once I get the job I want this promotion
or I want to go to this school or even
you know something as trivial as I would
like to try this kind of candy over here
and you know that you just don't get to
do it
those are disappointments those are not
what we might call disappointments on a
fundamental moral or ontological level
that ties in with the absurd so what
does he have in mind he says you know
there's wild longing for clarity we're
going to explore that in a moment
says the absurd depends as much on man
as on the world for the moment it is all
that links them together that's a really
important point what's going on here is
you don't have a self this is very you
know sort of typical late modern
philosophy you don't have a self as an
individual existing all by itself
outside of the world the self explores
what it is finds out what it is
learns about its capacities by engaging
with things outside of it that's
side of itself you know whether this be
objects in the environment or whether
these be other cells other human beings
through it is connected with on the
other hand and this is something that
you know modern philosophy has been very
good about revealing you don't have a
world existing as world as something
that can be perceived something that's
meaningful without having subjectivity
that is engaged with the world so you
might say from a communion perspective
were human beings not to be there you
wouldn't you would have things you might
say you even have a universe but you
wouldn't have a world you wouldn't have
something that can confront a human
being something that is organized to
some degree that has meaning to some
degree it's the fact that it is meeting
to some degree that allows it to even be
absurd in the first place so the absurd
depends just as much on Manas on the
world and he says from for the moment it
is all that links them together it binds
them one to the other as only hatred can
weld two creatures together this is all
I can discern clearly in this
measureless universe where my adventure
takes place so if we want to say where
is the absurd it's not just in the self
it's not just some sort of morbid
personality quirk that somebody might
have where they just don't find meaning
in things even though other people do
nor is it out there in the world so that
everybody ought to be able to get it you
know it's something that's completely
clear to anyone who just looks at the
world it's in the engagement between the
self and the world which means that it's
going to be individuated which means
also that to a certain degree you you
can outline general features of the
absurd but you can't completely wrap
your head around what it means for the
absurd to be outside of the proof that
side of the perspective of individual
human beings for whom there is absurdity
in the relationship between self and
world so now we want to actually look at
this and Camus spells out a few
different ways in which this happens and
again remember the relationship between
intellect and activity when we're doing
this he says as soon as the human being
begins to really think begins to think
things through what they're going to see
is that things don't completely add up
they don't completely make sense and
when we think we think in part
reflexively inside of our inside of our
self right we make ourselves into
objects of thought but much of it is an
engagement between us in the world we're
trying to think the world we're trying
to make sense out of the other people
that we have to deal with the history
that were involved in the systems you
know the the environment the physical
objects that we have to endure engage
explore so it says the minds deepest
desire what it is that our intellects
really want the most even in its most
elaborate operations parallels man's
unconscious feeling in the face of this
universe what is the relationship that
the subject has to the environments he
says that it's an insistence on
familiarity and appetite for clarity
understanding the world for a man is
reducing it to the human stamping it
with his seal the truism all thought is
anthropomorphic has no other meaning we
want the world to be a familiar place
comfortable reliable someplace that
actually makes sense to us and he says
if man realized that the universe like
him can love and suffer if the universe
were really like us he would be
reconciled if thought discovered in the
shimmering mirrors of phenomena eternal
relations capable of summing them up and
summing themselves up in a single
principle then would be seen an
intellectual joy of which the myth of
the Blessed would be
ulis imitation we want order we want
things to make sense he calls this a
nostalgia for unity the appetite for the
absolute me says this illustrates the
essential impulse of the human drama we
want things to make sense we want them
to be rational we want there to be
meaning that we can rely on not just
meeting up here at the superficial level
meaning running all the way down to the
very roots of being the problem is
that's not what the world is going to
provide you that's not what you get in
this environment that's not what you'll
ever get he thinks we've always got this
nostalgia for something that we feel is
lost or missing but it was never there
to begin with we never had that and
we're always seeking and we want that
from the world and the world can only
give that to us if in fact the world is
rational but unfortunately the world
although it is rational in parts locally
is not globally rational you might say
well yeah but everything's subject to
natural laws remember this is a
humanized universe it's not just the
fact that say gravity exists everywhere
we want things to make sense to human
beings and not just the stunted sort of
human being that ever thinks of
everything in terms of saying
mathematics or Natural Science but the
human being that can actually feel think
desire understand the entire universe in
terms of human qualities while the
universe doesn't get that it gives it in
parts but those are always localized
those are always vulnerable those are
always subject as soon as we start
thinking soon as we start exercising
thought upon it that all those end up
getting corroded away it's fragmented he
says he has a beautiful passage
where he says uh with its first move
this world cracks and tumbles an
infinite number of shimmering fragments
is offered to the understanding we must
despair of ever reconstructing the
familiar calm surface which would give
us peace of heart which would satisfy
our desires after so many centuries of
inquiry so many applications among
thinkers we are well aware that this is
true for all of our knowledge only
rationalist people who have a sort of
blind faith in science or logic or
rationality really think according to
Camus that we can find in the world this
thing that would actually conform to our
deep desires so of whom and of what
indeed can I say I know that I
understand this through and through
this heart within me I can feel an eye
judge that exists this world I can touch
an eye like wise judge that it can exist
that it exists there ends all my
knowledge all the rest is construction
all the rest is what I project out onto
the world and that's not reliable that
could be up for doubt as a matter of
fact he's not just a Cartesian saying
well you know I could doubt this he's
actually saying well when you actually
put it to the test usually it falls
apart our understanding of ourselves our
understanding of the world our
understanding of others that we take as
reliable knowledge oftentimes it turns
out not to be so the things that turn
out to be reliable turn out to be
meaningless there's another problem so
he says between a certainty I have of my
existence and the content I try to give
to that assurance the gap will never be
filled I will always be a stranger to
myself all the knowledge on earth will
give me nothing to assure me that this
world is mine you describe it to me and
you teach me to classify it you
enumerate its laws and in my thirst for
knowledge I admit that they're true you
take apart mechanism and my hope
increases at the final stage you teach
me that this wondrous and multicolored
universe can be reduce
the atom and this atom can be reduced to
the electron all this is good I wait for
you to continue seems like we're
actually getting to the rationality that
we want but then you tell me of an
invisible planetary system in which
electrons gravitate around a nucleus you
explain this to me with an image I
realize you have been reduced to poetry
poetry is not what did you know science
pretended to be something reliable
something that will give me the
assurance that my nostalgia is driving
me towards so the world is absurd
insofar as it participates in the
absurdity that's taking place in this
contradiction between what the self the
human subject desires to find out there
in the world that's why there can be
absurdity in the world so he says to
will to desire to want anything is to
stir up paradoxes so this applies just
as much to our our heart our affective
side is it as it applies to our mind our
intellectual side it all ends up turning
out to be absurd according to come ooon
everything isn't ordered in such a way
he says as to bring into being that
poisoned peace produced by
thoughtlessness lack of heart or fatal
renunciations so the intelligence tells
me in its way that this world is absurd
it's contrary blind reason sort of a
ideological I'm going to hide my head in
the sand just pretend everything's okay
hiding from oneself hiding from the
world you know fooling oneself says that
everything is clear but that's not going
to work for us once we become aware
attune to this this gap this this
irreconcilable separation that we can't
actually get away from because we're not
truly separate this
infinite desire that we have on our part
which can never be satisfied by the
things that we turn to we must recognize
come who thinks absurdity but the
absurdity this is what I want to really
stress and this is what I want to end
with the absurdity does not lie here or
here alone
it lies in all three of these and most
particularly in this confrontation
between the two sides only that really
gives us the absurd